ladies and gentlemen please welcome our
host
her majesty whoopi goldberg
[Music]
thank you bill good evening loyal
subjects i am the african queen
[Applause]
some of you may know me as the virgin
queen
but i can't imagine who
it is my solemn task this evening to
welcome you to the 71st
annual academy awards ceremony a
ceremony devoted to rewarding the many
many people this year
who played me
yes
[Applause]
or wrote about me
or designed lovely frocks for me
because darling it's all about me
thank you
i would thank you further but they're
telling me we're already running late
this will be a long show so we don't
want to read about how damn long it was
we know it's long
tough now
you know
[Applause]
it's the biggest night in hollywood baby
but be that as it may i think we've all
had our hair done enough times to know
that you cannot rush
a queen
not that i wish to reinforce negative
stereotypes
but i will say your reception has been
most kind
so i will withdraw and return this gown
to my dearest subject
and friend sir elton john
and i will be back once i've taken the
imperial
we we